[Music]
there put some mug in the basket I it
puts the mug in the basket it does
whatever its toll Oh place of a mug in
the basket I I just can't really push
the ball to the basket or gets the hose
again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes that is the sound of the weekend
because it is the Thursday livestream on
the YouTube so glad to be with you we
were in Virginia Tech rattling so there
was no show I haven't introduced you yet
great guests roaming millennial we have
the hodgetwins who are always
entertaining and hey we're still alive
budgets budgets save lives producer with
me in video studio as always as Jared
who is now a filing on Twitter and not
gay Jared me at as credit with your
comments your thoughts your photo shops
your t-shirts if you came out to a
recent show pictures I fulfill my legal
obligations draw your own conclusions
are we good we are good mostly at G
Morgan Jr is here sommelier and chief
simplified wine.com what's one of the
day you didn't take me to Virginia Tech
we didn't take you to bring your tech
and with good reason for example Paul
Paul Meyer Meyer our show helping with
research and overlays at Sen computer
doing well hello yeah by the way that's
fine computer soiled himself at Virginia
Tech no no joke there's hundreds out I
better look at my shoes look they're
vets now I think I consult bill Richmond
yep yeah sorry he doesn't work with
crowds
all right you must go so uh question of
the day we were going everyone's time
off I see and we're talking about the
budget that was okay we'll talk about
that but Lori mainly want to talk about
Prime Minister Trudeau and obviously he
did the people kind comment recently so
we went back to the archives and just
looked at the worst most cringe-worthy
but we have a top five on Trudeau but I
asked you this hint it was hard to
choose yes it was very very difficult to
call it down there's no winner really
there's no top five it's a low light
less of a highlight which this is a
question remove your political goggles
for a second who do you genuinely think
is more mockable
I think if you're even if you're North
Korean and they asked like Kim jong-un
yeah I could see how you think he's a
character
you know like Trudeau or president
Donald Trump obviously President Donald
Trump has some gaps but Trudeau just
uses social justice warrior lexicons
like ones
we don't even a lexicon I don't even
think the social justice where your
lexicon publishers knew existed
ironically if you're just gonna take
someone and run a highlight and say I'm
not going to write anything to make fun
just listen to him who do you think is
more embarrassing who do you think runs
the country yes
oh yeah that's actually good point
there's no doubt as to President Trump
that he runs the country they allowed
you to be a father much less all right
went to get to news today Nancy Pelosi
of course you know this we had to talk
about an eight-hour marathon speech that
she had set the record for longest
continuous speech at least since 1909
boy of course many suspected it was just
a complex marketing scheme by Snickers
as evidence when Pelosi concluded her
speech with a chocolate bar and turned
into being a not not I'm still guys
fiber netic founder yeah sent from the
future to destroy us all I'm gonna see
that on network TV we just figure we
start out right out of the gate let you
know we're about San Diego let's show
boom san diego's adopted now new
safeguards against skew homeless people
the city garbage truck San Diego
officials have completed investigation
following some near deaths with homeless
people last year and have issued new
rules to make sure that doesn't happen
again a lot but San Diego a lot of
people think San Francisco San Diego
obviously a lot of homeless people yeah
really big cities in California so they
did this investigation they've released
a memo and some of the changes actually
makes sense you know for example garbage
trucks in San Diego used to come on
Mondays and Thursdays and now they'll be
coming never they just to avoid all the
people in the gut that's the only
solution silly leftists you could have
just recycle worthless
yeah that's what we need to do thought
it was corn the renewable resource to
take us into the future is hobo Merrill
I'm pretty sure Johnny Depp is just a
recycled hobo yes back from the grave
yeah he's a hobo who lives he's
energized through the power of beating
women you could also not hit I mean this
is pretty
well rent control that's it's hard to
get rid of that man at your is contract
man well you know he does sorry in
Ithaca high school just canceled their
Hunchback of Notre Dame musical after a
white student landed the lead role
because at best this is cultural
appropriation the student group wrote
alleging racial bias from the Performing
Arts program at IHS and quote at worst
it is whitewashing a racist casting
practice which has its roots in
minstrelsy yeah this is well actually
this is where we are now the outrage is
the lead in Hunchback of Notre Dame yeah
so it really shouldn't come as any
surprise we spurred this curious protest
seemingly at first if it goes own MC
hunch back in his noted sidekick DJ
little moto this one was just kind of
scraping people not offended all of the
blacks and Ithaca who aren't hunchbacks
it's a new frontier by the way we still
have in 1740s France black royalty and
powdered wigs and white face and Beauty
and the Beast we're gonna make that's
okay punch pack of Notre Dame
there's no one fighting for that I don't
know who's fighting for that it that's
that's the least role you would ever
want yeah aren't you that exactly
besides is probably you're like a funky
looking dude purpose a TV in there
anyways
Notre Dame in the show band I'm like oh
there's one that went right over Gerald
spend computer maybe you can fact check
some sense of humor firm bring that up
for the dome Tammy's upcoming Hunchback
it's time to hashtag hunch forward
that's all we're saying
lunch board okay here's a story that's
kind of sad but not I mean it's it is
sad but not to us
fentanyl was actually recently found in
Anna Locke's own kit given out at a
pharmacy oops
so fentanyl which the well noted opioid
painkiller was accidentally placed into
a naloxone kit which is for those who
don't know it's kind of like methadone
is to heroin it's a kit designed to wean
people off of painkiller addiction
of course the pharmacist in question was
fired was the supervisor citing the
reason being that he like did the
only thing you're not supposed to do
with any opioid addiction kit it's the
first rule of painkiller don't give them
the customer in question was thinking
this is the easiest withdrawal ever
sobriety is its own reward is strikingly
similar start with the oh he's calling
all his family mom I feel good I feel
better than I've ever felt clean I'm
just you know what I'm really doing it
when they find out actually you just had
a higher dose of I've never had before
but I'm okay with it
was that part of you bit about a you
know a runner sighs just as good as
heroin I think guys like ever tried
heroin speaking of missing the mark
senator angus King of Maine has finally
accomplished what he set out to do in
getting an official lobster moji for
months the senator he lobbied for this
Lobster emoji highlighting its cultural
and economic significance to the state
let's bring us up CNN I think we just
run it for like two seconds there you go
on Wednesday the Unicode consortium is a
thing announced the emoji would be added
to its library a move that Senator King
has hailed as quote great news and we
want to risk shutting down this
government are you out of your tree sir
most happy about this new emoji all the
witty millennial sea-captains
yeah it's gonna come I guess more ammo I
don't need that next to your cat gifts
that guy's gonna be an editor BuzzFeed
watch very quickly
always so soon by the way I think
between the pitch meeting in this this
moment right now we missed there's new
black redheaded emojis oh that's right
yes those happen in nature well they do
they're called albinos and they
typically are they're typically
particularly soul sucking vampires
that's the truth yeah I get
uncomfortable twins who will be on later
in the show because they're black and
they have like light green eyes yeah I'm
like you got your you're a shoo-in for a
reboot of Buffy
no dad straight out of Blade yeah I
don't even have never watched played
because I watch better butter shows I
admitted it was worse is that a film
yeah played your but you're an adult
correct well at the time I was not sure
I was that kind of slow hey man you
gonna come with us you laid three pretty
no not at all that won't be there so
that we were we were facing you were
looking off the the cliff of a potential
government shutdown today so thinking we
all we just it is it is a dance with
death it is a cruel reality of nature
like every time we talk about this we'll
talk about it with Roman millennial it's
just whoever is the opposition party
just uses it as political football so
sure and by the way not a great deal
when you look at the increase not really
we're not really talking there are no
fiscal conservatives representing anyone
right now yeah well they'd see Pelosi
stay home have shut the government down
yes yes let's do it
right well people now people were
terrified terrified of what would happen
without the government and if you listen
to the news if it we know about what
would happen because we we've lived
through it
[Music]
breaking rules with a threat of a
government shutdown looming over the
United States of America money systems
find themselves uncertain as to the
outcome and unpredictable nature of
their immediate future and what
[Music]
you don't know who yours sometimes does
you love the most we fought for the
wrong side there are real big bucks hey
speaking of victims
so as fen computer you know I got flack
for talking on Joe Rogan about the the
normally high taxes in Germany for for
young men and and you were getting flack
for it so this is this is your segment
yes beep beep so Germany I love how he's
not nervous until he's in the hot seat
as like yeah yes we don't do well under
pressure
unless exerting it would you carry out
the service I'm a computer yeah I don't
know you're an insubordinate
once you've carried out the Holocaust
nothing fazes you he can joke about it
he has the Holocaust past okay go go
ahead stand by Peter correct because he
won't given you flak obviously and you
know you know this better than anyone
Germany has the second highest tax rate
in the world yes and the average tax
burden for a single person is forty nine
point four percent now 15 only fifteen
point nine percent beep beep of that is
your actual income tax right so
obviously a lot of other taxes like your
VA t v-- beep your your mandatory health
care okay
so there goes top tax bracket I think
it's forty two percent target is forty
two percent which starts at $65,000
already BP which you know it's not crazy
money exactly beep yeah and no added to
that of course is again your all your
medical stuff your health care your
Social Security or VA t so it comes out
as something pretty pretty crazy yeah
it's it's insane it's basically you are
paying an insane amount of taxes if you
are just a young male who is employed at
a normal level yeah but - don't go there
because you might pay high taxes or get
gassed god well using that pass won't we
need this button anymore well this will
be changed out for a an ice speed dial
they are the only one in our top five
right speaking of top five top five we
have today we want to talk about because
I keep wondering it's a Pierre Justin
Trudeau will have Canadian on roaming
one day after this did
the whole people kind but we'll get to
that but we have our five top Trudeau
cringe moments I want to ask you this as
someone who was Canadian I voted for
Stephen Harper how how do you guys see
Trudeau did you think about Canadian
politics at all before Trudeau because
it's kind of a celebrity I didn't know I
don't think I even knew who the Prime
Minister of Canada was before as she was
a paint maybe I wasn't paying attention
but I feel like he has been shoved in
the limelight because of the suave
little were you familiar with Stephen
Harper or not so much not at all okay he
was like our Ronald Reagan and that's I
was talking about Joe Rogan about it
going like listen like it's okay to mock
him but the fact is all these comedians
mocked Stephen Harper because he was the
Christian conservative right we didn't
have the housing crisis like he did a
really we were higher on the economic
freedom index for the first time in the
United States when he had Harper and
President Obama oh my god could you
imagine if we had eight years of overlap
between Trudeau and Obama oh that's the
stuff that gives kids nightmares I don't
think most Americans spend any time
thinking about Canadian politics though
so no a shoe earned himself in he seems
to be somewhat fashionable and he says
stupid stuff that the left loves nobody
they don't really but they don't know
they're stupid that's the thing is it is
like the sky like Kim jong-un but a
totally different lack of self-awareness
er yeah okay so let's go through the
worst possible moments I don't even
think Gerald has seen you so number five
we all agreed is his Bollywood dance
Fiasco let's roll that buy that outfit
and decided he was gonna do the girl
version of the band because that's a man
you want to trust national security
there's like in a back room at a why I'm
in the back room at a Hilton Garden Inn
haha
they only got half the room to the only
thing more cringy itself is the
Canadians just fawning over it
they're just love them I remember seeing
JB Rochelle in the interview recently
he's like well you know we uh we like
our Prime Minister obviously was Trump
and now you know we tease him a bit you
know he's very good-looking
insufferable just absence mind-numbing
walking vagina that's one you make fun
of him okay metaphor is uh who can
forget this one he was asked why he had
so many women in his cabinet what
obvious answer is obvious I understand
one of the priorities for you was to
have a cabinet that was gender balanced
why was that so important to you
because it's 2015 I look it's met with
cheers just as surely if he'd have said
because they're the most qualified
people for the job and that's the only
reason he would have been met with Oh
exactly spot two looks like ah yeah
prepare for this that's how easily there
a law days it what day is it the left is
that all the time we've talked about it
they just say it's time for this yeah
it's time for same-sex marriage okay
it's time for an all-woman cabinet I
guess it's time for a black president
I never realized time for a woman
president old on I was telling it before
it's time
there's Bruce Buffer wire chop tied four
drafts I've equal equality marriage in
and just just filling the gap with
arcade machine it's time psyphon to
promote a paedophile three times in a
row it's time it's time for generic old
white guys to beat the till over the
ship every now and then hardest people I
don't but I said it's time that's true
doesn't that work okay so number three
is the recent one let's analyze this
this is one of course the infamous from
this week people kind joke and I'm aware
as to what people say about this clip
let's roll at first maternal love is the
love that's going to change the future
of mankind
so we'd like you to look we would like
to say people kind not necessarily
mankind
okay yes thank you we can all learn from
each other now he said that's a joke
mm-hmm she's clearly not aware it's a
joke the audience not aware it's a joke
and it seems not like the kind of a joke
that a progressive would make now this
is where the took the preponderance
evidence the totality of all the clips
we show you would lead one to believe
it's not a joke because he could watch
it and say I think maybe what no I don't
think it was a joke and something else
this is actually what what happened with
Andrew Breitbart this is a story Shirley
Sherrod everyone came down on him
because Shirley Sherrod was fired she
worked in the agricultural department
again people know the exact title she
was giving a speech to the n-double-a-cp
and she talked about a white farmer
coming to her and she said I didn't I
did not offer him the full extent of my
help because of his race and the
n-double-a-cp claps now when Andrew
Breitbart posted this article he posted
it and he said just so you know at
minute 20 her humanity eventually gets
the better of her and she does go on to
say that she then realized it wasn't
about race and she helped white and
black farmers alike so this was posted
the original time Andrew Breitbart
posted the video he said but the
reaction from the n-double-a-cp at that
snapshot in time was to clap and sheer
simply at her saying I didn't help the
white person right so he was and then of
course an editor at Bill O'Reilly took
it out of context thought we can make
this lie sexier than the truth and
Shirley Sherrod got fired and they said
Andrew Breitbart into that context when
he never did his point was the
n-double-a-cp reaction the reaction
there from the audience tells no one
there thought it was a joke no yeah you
said you also said inclusive yeah you
progressives and joke about inclusivity
like now after following this is after
the women in cabinet
yeah I've team now sudden it's it's a
topic right for satire the exercise a
problem with the English language man is
inclusive yeah man does not necessarily
mean just you you can use it to mean
everyone come on yeah I know but that's
the thing is because they're trying to
score points with a fence I know yeah
exhausting what you looking at jump in
there same computer yeah well be
whenever I see Trudeau I just I just
want to actually embraces his lifestyle
babe if you just stance and then off the
mirror every morning just goes how
they're such a giant
you never know what you're gonna get
from that German you're a terrible
computer but I think you okay here's
number two because we couldn't fit them
all in number two as far as were the low
light I guess of Justin Trudeau is just
this is just a montage of him weeping
here I thought I was gonna make it
through this but I know now you didn't
it hurts
everything does with you so my memory is
that that moment went back to my Syria -
that's a be blasted eyes something wraps
wrong in your community your province
your country the world all of that color
goes away and we become a family so you
made a contribution to a nation by the
way here's one thing I don't want to be
like like there's nothing wrong with a
man crying when appropriate okay I'm not
that guy says you can never cry but one
thing that there's everything crying in
it being your calling card right and
then you cry you wanna you want to avoid
if you actually cry and it's at a point
where it just you were touched and that
happened that that's actually Hunchback
of Notre Dame was really made me cry
that and the Fox and the Hound Oh got
really tough to like but you know if
you're there with your wife and like
okay probably should be crying at this
it's something you kind of keep settled
you don't have a tissue
ready and dab it like you don't want to
destroy your blush the leader of the
northern free world by the way that
that's his wife next to them yeah and so
he in the loose also with the word [ __ ]
their cycles are aligned if not they're
probably doing some chances I'm sure
that they are okay genuine though right
we know somebody I'm not gonna say the
name we know somebody who's calling card
is to cry at these moments you you I
can't say who it is on air and I can't
give away anything but it seems very I
know this person yes yes you do oh okay
I think it doesn't seem genuine at all
every time you're like oh okay okay now
you're doing it I was doing the crank
alright we get it now okay it used to be
one for you now I just don't like and
number one here's why this is why I
don't think it was a joke this is why I
think when people go back and forth we
talked about this at Virginia Tech when
people go back and forth say this was a
joke it wasn't a joke take it in context
then go beyond the context of just a
clip
kind of like we do this rebuttal with
Vox earlier this week go beyond the
context of
clip and then include the context of
character lifestyle over with with
Trudeau there is so much evidence we
weren't able to show you all of it but I
think this one is possibly the most
damning our number one worst Trudeau
Prime Minister of Canada for real moment
we are here today together reminding
ourselves and each other that we can and
must do better better for the oppression
here comes a lesbian gay bisexual
transgender queer and spirit communities
[Laughter]
if we were to say too spirited if we
were to include that in the acronym last
year you would have said it was a straw
man you would have said come on now no
one really uses the two-spirit if I was
elder what you're gonna say now LGBTQA a
IP with a number two yes like a
pansexual bike okay asexual Ally you
jumped right to two-spirit yeah op
scotch and went to the craziest one
everything pre-med and post weep makes
us want to saw our own heads off with
that clip that's why I don't think these
terms that even the worst like deep
within the bowels of the deep Internet
of social justice warrior 'dom they
couldn't use his vernacular with a
straight face like right now you could
go down to the local [ __ ] walk or
feminist March and say what do you think
about LGBTQA a IP number two maybe like
what and you'd say to spirited the
biggest anger is blue-haired feminist er
Blake don't be a dick and this is the
Prime Minister we're not doing use it
all right listen we do have to get go we
gonna have a roaming millennial she's
Canadian we'll ask her about him will
talk about Vice and we'll talk about the
band then we have hodgetwins will just
probably talk about something that we
don't anticipate so as always
expectations low for the hodgetwins
[Music]
and now for barely legal with Bill
Richmond sponsored by McLeod hi Bill
Richmond louder with Crowder's
half-asian lawyer here to explain
sometimes confusing legal terms and
concepts today we're talking about
different types of courts that exist to
solve legal issues first up family court
divorce child custody you probably know
what I'm talking about but if you don't
think OJ Simpson and Nicole Browns first
fight but with less blood and no gloves
next is probate court where you resolve
post at issues like wills and estates
and inheritances it's the place Anna
Nicole Smith hung out on weekends hoping
for a pot of gold general jurisdictional
court is a potpourri of judicial forums
you get a little civil a little criminal
little family little probate a lot of
small time small County courts are like
that then you go to the next level the
court of appeals where someone smarter
is gonna be checking your work and
finally the Supreme Court at the top dog
in most states and the United States in
some states though like New York they
just want to be different in honoré they
call their basic court the Supreme Court
and then their top court the Court of
Appeals animals
I hope this clarifies the issue for you
though considering this is the internet
you probably forgot half of what I said
and will send me a letter anyways asking
the same question in a week I will not
respond I'm half asian lawyer bill
Richman for a louder with Crowder Cheers
this has been barely legal with Bill
Richmond
sponsored by mug club
[Music]
I know what this is fuse in the club
your poison there's something important
in someone else's your head pointing you
out the door
yeah you know who never gets pointed out
the door at the club our next guest
she's lovely but she look like she's got
the gates of hell right now
he follow her on the Twitter at roaming
millennial and here she is she's her new
show obvious it's ER TV if your mug Club
member if you join over there at CR T V
Roman millennial uncensored because I
tell you what when I think I'm a
millennial I think I think censored
filthy mouth yes
how are you MS millennial I am good
thank you so much for having me on
so what is so this is a fireplace behind
you but it's something like from a Bugs
Bunny cartoon where there this would be
if you listen to the the bad devil on
his shoulder and then you end up there
yeah well the theme we were going for
was kind of like edgy looks like a place
you'd want to drink scotch
I don't drink scotch but when people
look at my set I want them to think oh
yeah well what a classy place so I
really like it given I think classy I
think half Asian Canadian drinking
scotch and from an electric fireplace
right isn't that just like the epitome
of like moneyed opinions it's like next
step is white glove service are the bars
so simple roaming your show just started
recently here at launch your new year at
CR TV right how's this guy is it is it
nerve-wracking for you excited it's
exciting
I'm having a lot of fun with it I'm at
this stage now or there I have so many
different segments that I want to do
that my producer was actually kind of
like okay like we're kind of at the
point now where every different stories
its own segment so maybe we just try to
keep to the like eight we have so far
custard is only a 1020 minutes show but
it's a lot of fun and I like the new
format I'm really really liking you know
all of the the fancy equipment and stuff
it's just it's so much of a step up from
what I'm used to
that's it I'm in the honeymoon phase the
moments more work but I think it's worth
is know is there any threat of a roaming
millennial shutdown looks like we've
probably avoided that here but of course
everyone was afraid the sky is falling
the the government shutdown am I the
only one who when this happens every
year
I couldn't care less well I I know you
know just this past time that everyone
was freaking out and I was kind
thing like do you guys not remember that
this has actually happened before in
recent history I think meaning 2013 I
was doing my internship in DC at the
time and it's like I mean yeah yes yes
it's awful but I think a lot of people
don't understand what government shut
down access not really meals shut down
it's more like government light for a
couple days right they're gonna for
shutdown it's like yeah it's it's it's
you know a little bit lesser version
yeah kind of like going down to Coke
Zero yeah it's still Coke Lindsey
Graham's gonna grow one more chin maybe
because he's not getting on the
elliptical yeah I don't what is what is
you know Canadians I guess I don't know
if they fully understand what what is
the the fear maybe we can talk with
Hodgins I understand exactly what the
fears of the government shutdown
shutdown hmm are they not gonna collect
taxes I'm pretty sure they obviously I
don't want to minimize the effect this
has to people like you know military
members who I know it does really affect
the their ability to do things like
claim benefits and stuff like that I
think maybe even their pay so yeah I
don't want to minimize it too much but I
think the last time you know I know all
the staffers that I was working with
there their pay wasn't coming in so
sucked for them especially since you
know they're living in DC so pretty much
living paycheck to paycheck you know
last time they made a big show of
shutting down national parks and even
outdoor monuments that you know like it
actually required them to spend more
money closing them off and make sure
they're being watched rather than just
let people walk through them but I think
I must feel very conflicted to like I
hate the government shutdown but George
Washington was also a racist so I'm just
gonna burn a Walgreens
let's go a burnable yes back straight
yes CVS sorry yeah but I think a lot of
people there they're scared by it just
because you know is shut down they don't
know like what our police could have
stopped working you know does this mean
North Korea can just come get us no one
knows apparently that's what's scary we
do know in Canada North Korea can always
come and get you yeah yes they that
you're the first stop they just you know
if they decided to act up okay well
there's not a whole lot to it looks like
we've mainly avoided it the deal you
another three hundred billion increase
in caps I do find it funny that everyone
always plays political football raising
the debt ceiling if you're talking about
that every time I shut down of course
whenever whenever it comes to talk about
the debt ceiling remember that it's just
basically whenever these budget talks
come up whoever is
the party not in charge they take the
moral high ground and go how could you
do this right how could you let this
shut down but think about the last time
you were saying that they were letting
it shut down when they were the
opposition party I don't really care all
that much anymore before we go on to
something else I know you wanted to talk
about your Canadian and Winter Olympics
so is this like is this this is the
moment where Canada gets to shine they
usually do really well in the Winter
Olympics so I'm not gonna lie
I don't watch those yeah okay Winter
Olympics I know I know we do good in
hockey question mark but I'm a Summer
Olympics kind of a kind of person it's
just like I don't like the snow and it
makes me cold watching other people will
be in the snow yeah well yeah but you
kind of kind of you're in the worst
possible place if you hate snow it is
awful terrible awful place I mean like I
I think the word habitable is used
wrongly when described yes yeah I know
it's really not is it like the weather
is trying to kill you yes that's a good
point it's basically it's it's a
struggle it's kind of like when I was
recently at Big Bear by the way nothing
apparently they sell nothing but Owen
Benjamin tchotchkes in big it's nothing
but big red Jessica's like altitude is a
struggle you're basically struggling to
survive with each breath you're going
and you're longer saying no [ __ ] I
didn't say I didn't say you could do
this right now
it is hard and that's what Canada is you
walk out with Montreal anyway it's so
cold
human beings we're not meant to live
this so you spray exactly and actually
we we had the issue where our propane
tank ran out because there was an
especially cold week just recently it
was like minus 40 so we're using more
heat and actually the our propane
company really dropped the ball so we we
didn't have propane and actually ran out
it was like it was it went from 20
degrees Celsius in our house to like 10
and it was kept dropping but they
couldn't actually come fill the tank cuz
we'd also had a lot of snow so we
actually had to go shovel it it was this
whole thing we were at we didn't have
heat for like two days and yeah let me
tell you this is not a place where you
can live without electricity no that is
it is not but by the way electricity not
necessary I don't think you really sure
because Haiti is still a beautiful
wonderful country and powder Canada you
have all the lgbtq it's too spiritual to
be warm
yes the tolerance is what keeps you warm
and also the body temperature set tiers
of Pierre Trudeau Justin I always said
the answer no they're both the word
because obviously we just did a story
before you came out even get seen a
top-five awful moments with with Trudeau
and it was so hard
yeah it is it is hard to pick one so
tell us about this you were you're
talking with us on your show 120
decibels I think I have that do I have
that right
there's femke tell us again yes he's a
big picture yeah who don't know and
you've been kind of following this story
right so 120 decibels is this movement
that started with German woman to try
and bring attention to the wave of sex
waves of sexual assaults that have been
happening in Germany because of the
whole migrant crisis thing and you know
people in the alternative media we you
know they've been talking about this for
for a long time trying to bring
attention to this issue the fact that
these countries which had previously
some of the lowest rate statistics in
the world they're actually going up
dramatically right and it's funny
because usually rape culture women being
sexually assaulted that's something that
progressives love to talk about right
that's like that's like gold they love
that stuff but because of the people who
are actually doing it these migrants it
really doesn't get any attention and
they're actually been instances where we
know that the police have tried to cover
it up because they didn't want to draw
attention to this problem for fear of
appearing intolerant right and you know
for me this this isn't about race right
I couldn't care less I was gonna be a
question because I know some people said
some of this you know some of these
statistics come from sort of the
identitarian right who slant them
sometimes so I I know that you're
probably aware of that that was that
would be one of the criticisms they lob
right yeah and I know you know anytime
something like the migrant crisis comes
up in your in in Europe that's always
you know the the people who are most
vocal about it right now frankly are the
alt-right and the identitarian and you
know I'm not all right
I'm not identitarian but at the same
time we can't deny that this problem
exists and just because people I don't
like are also talking about it I don't
want to you know ignore it and say no
it's it's not a big deal right because I
you know I think people can both be
wrong on this subject you know the
progressives who want these open borders
and to ignore this problem they're wrong
and the people who look at these
problems and say up
ethnocentrism the fact that you know
they're people a lot of peace people
coming in are not vetted you know they
have probably criminal histories and
their own companies but we just don't
know about it because you know it's just
kind of this like open free-for-all
right now and you know even people who
are being caught they're not being sent
back and it's it's because of political
correctness so I I can criminal record
right away let's be real here that's a
very low bar with a lot of these
countries that they're coming from if
there's a criminal record you done some
stuff because it doesn't make the list
you know it's and by the way yeah if you
remove the identitarian idea of it or
this the sort of racial politics from it
this happened in Detroit to where murder
rates increased they actually fluffed up
the number the population number in
Detroit and because so many murders will
go unsolved they just they found a way
to tweak the numbers and if you search
it right now you can't exist exactly
what they did I think we did a piece on
it a while back but people said well how
sudden did the murder rate go like this
and then drop and they used different
different measurements right they used a
different barometer kind of like job
participation rate all of a sudden
nobody was including that when we were
talking about unemployment so it happens
sometimes when people just want to cover
their ass you could have police who
could be identitarian themselves but
they're gonna cash doesn't like we're
doing a good job let's find a way to
massage these numbers and the fact is
throughout human history if you'll get
relatively recently human history right
let's say the last half a century
violent crime and rape murder has
consistently been going down people like
to act as though everything is going to
hell maybe ideologically maybe people
financially are being irresponsible I
get that they're on their phones too
much texting and driving and get it but
murder rape has been going down so for
this to happen in the Western world to
go up it is startling historically I
don't think people understand that
regardless where they line up right
right very much so and I think the issue
for me is that I you know I really feel
for these women because they're in
countries where you know you can't just
have like oh you know castle lost hand
your grandma's law second of hit me
right maybe doesn't work like that over
there and I think the reason why I'm so
interested in it because I look at
what's happening in Canada right where
we're kind of I would say in in the
position of Sweden like maybe like 15
years earlier and I think with people
like Justin Trudeau empowered there's
the actual legitimate possibility
of us becoming Sweden part two in Canada
so you know I want to talk about these
issues so people can understand that you
know it's great to virtue signal how how
wrong it is to not take in refugees you
know by the tens of thousands if not
more but you know everything has cause
and effect there are actual legitimate
security concerns to think about here
and it's not just you know terrorist
attacks which are obviously awful but
you know there's there's much like less
serious I guess also crimes that happen
on an individual level yes like like
like food code of conduct that happens
they should all be getting an F yeah
when it comes to the sanitary department
you do remember in California I was
eating in a breakfast place one time for
years when I lived in LA and turned out
how to be from whatever that ratings in
California and I thought well it's ABC
in my friend said no no no B is like
next stop they're serving pigeon from
the roof W do not go to be you never
consider it it turns out that's why I
was violently ill we can sell all these
there's a food truck in it's called Kogi
there's a couple of them but there's one
of their food trucks that's in Santa
Monica that has like a C or something or
at least I did when I was there but it's
still so good yeah
haha Kenny Wong in bro siren where I was
raised they would just be shut down that
is one thing I will say the Asians are
very resourceful it's like they shut
them down like no no Han a second you
can't serve Seagal free food okay they
shut down go bankrupt it's just another
name it's the same guy we had like the
same rest was Kenny Wong had maybe 15
different names google it in the South
Shore of Montreal oh and we just
expected it you came to expect it I was
like couldn't we put the can we put
these people in jail as some crime being
committed here that's the same sign what
one time didn't even there's change I
think the Lenny Wong you just didn't
even change just took the portion of the
K and made it an L and and and still
with the bad shrimp we can solve it all
just by passing a budget more money okay
it is roaming millennial uncensored CR
tv.com of course see our TV if your mug
club member and people can still watch
them you stuff on YouTube where is there
anything else that I'm missing sorry
miss millennial know they got the
YouTube still posting videos there one
out of every three episodes of
uncensored that airs on see our TV is
mirrored on YouTube Twitter at roaming
mail
that's pretty much it sounds good and
stay tuned every what do you want to
watch the stuff
Oh millennial uncensored
[Music]
shut down time with no federal
government who will tap our phones shut
down time one last call to build the
wall and send all the illegals home with
no federal government who tears down the
monuments will tsa still fondle my balls
no more fake entitlements feel free to
keep your armaments they can't hurt us
anymore
I
loves to [ __ ] and moan I know
who wants to rape my home I know wants
to block my kids hormones and launch
some draw
shut down time who will sell uranium to
put it add some more to a
shut down time feds don't care about
opioids vet suicides unless they are
trans shut down time buffalo in
yellowstone are going unprotected
tonight shut down time more soy for all
the boys so they have low tea and they
cannot fight fight I know
want to raid my home I know who has
closets for bones I know
love to tap our phones and block our
kids homes
closing time
every great depression comes from
governments that overspend don't
threaten us with a good time federal
government see you later
don't you come back on now for barely
legal with Bill Richmond sponsored by
McLeod I'm bill Richmond louder with
Crowder's half-asian lawyer here to
explain sometimes confusing legal terms
and concepts in ancient times you
resolved your dispute with a spear a
club or smallpox blankets in modern
times you solved those problems with a
paper cut in one of a few types of
dispute resolution arenas the first one
is litigation typically refers to civil
lawsuits battled in front of a judge or
a jury in a courtroom
next is arbitration typically a binding
trial not in a courtroom but in front of
an arbitrator who is often times an old
lawyer or former judge there to give you
the whole time next is a mediation
non-binding formalized negotiations
where a mediator beats up both sides to
make them come to a resolution that
neither of them is happy with now as a
bonus term we have another shin
deposition it's a sworn
question-and-answer session often
videotaped where a witness or party gets
asked questions nothing is decided here
and there is no referee so don't be that
dumbass who says oh man there guy got
sued and lost in court when simply
referring to a deposition it makes you
sound like an idiot because you are one
I'm half asian lawyer bill Richman for a
lot of crowder
cheers this has been barely legal with
Bill Richmond sponsored by mug club
[Music]
all right glad that this is si shouldn't
have done this because right when you
bring these next guests they have their
mind in the gutter you better have your
hand on the center button ready I got it
ready you can follow them live at
hodgetwins tor.com to go see where their
live shows are it's pretty gets pretty
little Isis yeah guess it gets pretty
raucous some might say pg-13 maybe a
strong nc-17 at hodgetwins on the
Twitter Twins how are you sirs oh we're
doing great I like you
every now and then I get like you know
guests say hey we want to talk about
something and it gets sent to me before
the show okay I can usually talk about
the news right but every now and they
say we want to talk about something so I
do have from you something about Richard
Pryor this is not something about they
wanted to discuss with Eisley fryer
precisely sleeping with Marlon Brando
the floor is yours gentlemen I don't
know this is I think Marlon Brando was
too Bob yeah he's definitely the bottom
rich it was Tom he was the top I don't
see Richard doing any bottom ash now
what is where did you did you read about
like was there some some act some sort
of version of behind the candelabra that
was multicultural that I hadn't heard
about neither Twitter stuck in 2004 okay
no nobody dug it up this is Widow his
widow
yes Widow um one of his six wives one of
them came for and just started spilling
the beans on everything he did yeah I
saw YouTube videos the punch in the face
dude Iijima Richard Pryor yeah yeah we
releasing some Diaries and stuff right
yeah I think she's come out a book I
think that's why she's putting her stuff
out there she wants to get a book deal
yeah how true do you think it is and
that's kind of a something that we've
we've talked about before about what's
the hashtag me to movement like when you
have these outlandish claims it's hard
to sometimes believe it you wonder what
the motivation is because that
everyone's got an angle today kids yeah
yeah I believe it's probably true I saw
this up it was kind of like a
documentary style news kind of thing
that was talking to Richard Brian it was
talking to the same Widow she was saying
the right in his face you remember I
used to punch me in the face and ridges
like no I don't remember that
that one um it was a roast it was the
roast of uh right uh well who was it
just one of his friends it was another
comedian he was on some roast comedy
roast comedy roast right but they do not
days on comedy say yeah yeah you take
him up on stage and said he had just
first [ __ ] Hill men he said that I
knew he was telling the truth
yeah okay he wasn't joking it's being a
stand-up I mean you guys have some some
pretty big shows what's that like free I
will say this I had taken basically
hiatus from live shows for a year
because we were doing this show we were
going daily I didn't have any time I
said I can't do stand-up and focus in
the show so now we've taken the show on
the road and we were at Virginia Tech
and like you said before the show I was
roping off because it's seated about 550
people I was roping off the last few
rows because of comedy the last thing
you want is people spreading out right
you want him packed in there and I don't
know if we can fill this theater and
then it was filled to capacity standing
and then hundreds of people outside just
waiting to buy merch so now I have to
hold read just the whole show that was
the first time I'd ever really performed
to a thunderous audience who knew who we
were and were just excited to be there I
mean I imagine the energy is like that
with your shows they're there to have a
party right is a lot of like that for
you yes awesome experience I mean like
wizard philadelphi last night I was
about to ask you the same thing how it
went but yeah man it's it's like once
you put up a fan base and they already
really
who you are so they know to expect an
error they bought into who you are so
when they come to your show I mean it's
it's written for hearty mass a lot of
fun
Philadelphia taking your life their
hands after the Super Bowl people eating
horse if you know what's crazy
I could even book a hotel in
Philadelphia I wasn't thinking I waited
till last moment we I had to actually
buy a hotel in New Jersey mm-hmm 30
minutes away from the show yeah race
today yeah you haven't it's stupid
Philadelphia Eagle parade today yeah cuz
they want it for Super Bowl ooh not an
Eagles fan another Bud Light Dallas
Cowboys all the way downtown
little bit of pandering going on but we
appreciate it where you going next year
in Philly where's your next show next
show is in Washington DC to DC shows we
got to DC shows then we go into New
Brunswick New Jersey the New York City
and Atlanta hold on a second with ya
pause didn't you just peppered in there
like okay two shows in DC New Jersey New
Brunswick one of these things is not
like the other are you aware that your
brand of comedy might be some culture
shock to Maritimers with the Salt Lake
City yeah with the Minnesota Moon with
the Canada would Australia yeah baby
with people bought them tickets they
already go with good exploitations like
you might be the first black people
they've seen in the United States
they're relating to you there it's kind
of like paying a nickel to see a
carnival barker in a tent they just go
make you uncomfortable yeah yeah that's
bizarre
[ __ ] don't like black people but it's
more white people yeah I would say aber
sent white did I would say ten percent
Latino then I was saved
then I will say that Vietnamese what
makes you say Vietnamese can you
identify a Vietnamese person in a crowd
out of Chinese because the other stars
[Music]
okay all right listen let me let me ask
you this have you seen received any more
backlash because you know you won your
[ __ ] of the Year award before from
people who are black and now you've
talked about how you like ben shapiro
you've been in our show what's the
reaction been like that because i don't
want to say you guys are conservative
but you're certainly more out of the
closet now is politically incorrect and
not catering to the left have you seen
more backlash ever you see more positive
support I got this message from this
black one which is quite alarming I wish
I could sing you the message so she can
put it up but long story short the
message was this she says she's been a
big fan of us right she came to our show
I think was Boston
was it Boston yeah she came to our
Boston show she said she was coming
there to support black comedy I said
okay you already that's not what we do
then she goes on to say during the show
she's looking around and she was alarmed
by how many white people was there and
then what also pissed off was the black
guys that were there they were there
with white women which really set off
yeah and did she put that she's so
disappointed in us and I was like I was
gonna respond like yeah leave it alone
it is crazy because if you think about
it if there if there were a white woman
saying like I was so disappointed
because I saw I look and I thought white
women with like if some white woman sent
that in they would be crucified front
page if I PO be Joan of Arc just burnt
alive but it seemed I mean black women
are just totally fine looks like my
their territory they do there's this
real
territorial miss when it comes to black
man
yeah well it's a double standard I mean
look at this show blackest magic white
people came up with a show called
whiners yeah you guys might be on me
yeah yeah we would you're like you know
you're like you guys are like you're a
becoming black you're just black enough
to manage a white people it's a sitcom
about two Coons
there's no need brother way there's no
need for us to even be here one why are
we here when we tape the YouTube Carol
we could hear them coming down the
stairs it was an old stereo staircase
huh does that what do you call that it's
not a zigzag what do you call when his
chair goes back and forth between the
houses I think is it back and forth back
and forth staircase and you could hear
them today cartoon have yer see most
mostly backlash or do you feel like it's
been kind of liberating in your fanbase
has supported you because it's not like
you you guys have changed I just think
maybe some people didn't necessarily
know what they were getting if you look
at what you guys have talked about for a
long time entrepreneurs in the military
and very politically incorrect it I just
wonder if it maybe it didn't compute no
but you can't please everybody
suppose when it comes to common is so
subjective you just gotta be yourself
people people either gonna like you're
not gonna like you so what Hodge turns
toward a time people who are listening
now go out and support them have you had
some supporters they'll come out to him
be like hey man I you know now know I'm
a big fan of you guys know yeah it was
awesome it was like what was waiting
Columbus this woman kept coming she came
up to us and she couldn't stop saying
[ __ ] King breathe she was like hey
tears come on eyes I'm like yeah she was
still like a lot of people come to our
shows because you guys yeah no you sure
yeah well that's good
well I'm glad hodgetwins tour.com people
should go and support them because you
know listen their [ __ ] need to
breathe - it was that was often we've
had people come in and we we've had
people come in and do cameos and
sometimes it's been pretty rough for
it's like okay you got to stick to the
script
the [ __ ] key this was the first ad-lib
at the in a YouTube Carol that came from
the hodgetwins anyway this [ __ ] can't
breathe we looked at each other not good
Jared and I said okay we can work
relight wheat green light let's let them
run with it for a little bit and it was
great really good stuff really fun stuff
and you know what here's the kind of
thing I know a lot of people today all
it is is the fisa
and in the obvious of the budget so it's
boring I don't wanna talk about anymore
it's a really good feeling when you see
someone he said in tears laughing it
really is something that's a universal
language and unfortunately the left has
co-opted it in ruined it and tried to
tell us what's funny but just going out
and getting people laugh and that's
that's that's a service yeah yeah yeah
especially when it's old white lady
saying [ __ ] can't breathe
alright hodgetwins core calm at
hodgetwins your next aid is when it's
Washington DC that's on the 25th yeah
it's a Sunday I might be off all
information is that heart wins tor.com
all right
we'll be back after this to wrap this
program up in a nice rhythm hopefully
all of you
[Music]
join my club Papa needs more cheese's my
god I can only have it if you join my
club
[Music]
[Music]
some of you complain that we didn't do
the joining dance last week first show
back first job are you okay there I may
hurt myself
hurt yourself yeah what your head or
your back feel a pop pop a vessel no I'm
good
okay thank you by the way and the
hodgetwins we have some people I should
come up live and say hey I didn't know
if you were gonna do the drowning dance
people ratted us for show by the way we
did apologize the first show we did have
some technical issues I know with some
of the video stuff some of the sound
stuff you always want to concede it when
people are right it's true and what did
you do when you moved to a new studio
and it's like well second we moved to a
whole new editing space and yeah we did
get spend computer setup but we also a
big part of it was getting what we did
this week up and running with Virginia
Tech which was awesome it went
incredibly well and we're gonna have
other schools coming soon SMU I think is
next I'd be awesome
in early March I think I think with SMU
somewhere in Illinois somewhere in
Alabama so the Liberty kids are want to
beat it that's Roberti University if you
want us to come to your school you've
got to be hounding your school find a
local yeah chapter or see someone who
can bring us in because the school
doesn't fund bringing people in and
obviously we brought how many crew
members bring eight six or eight six or
eight and the camera is getting it's
it's you know it's expensive to bring it
if it in a lecture is it's it's not a
production it's whole entertainment show
yeah there's a whole bunch it's a stage
show plus we do this show live and the
reason we talked about it was because
you know this was I talked about this
with the hodgetwins now there's having a
healthy ego and then sometimes there's
having low self confidence and that's
kind of we talked about with me the
neuroticism with with Jordan Peterson I
didn't know that we're gonna be able to
fill up this theater can you understand
it this whole last year my my entire
life has been 100% dedicated to this
show because I know that you can only do
one thing really really well and I know
that this stage in my life we've talked
about this like I can't do stand-up and
this show and then be going that's why I
don't do really any cable news hits
unless they let me do it right from here
because I can't be shuttling tunes what
we just we don't have any time to do it
so we finally said okay going in the new
year well let's get the crew together
let's get the kit that we need to take
the show on the road and there were a
few glitches but it went really well but
human that's a whole year before I'd
even seen an audience so I don't think
we gonna fill this and it was just we
should have done to show an hour before
the show we were like how's it going out
there like they were like that's a fire
hazard yeah
this is yeah insane and I don't say
that's a brag I say that because when
you walked out just to prep people just
loved it it's a lot of fun it was a fun
energy there was so much like I said
there's a whole visual dynamic going on
lights and music it's not a lecture and
we want you to we wanted to be the party
on campus but I could see how compared
to when I was performing in you know
comedy clubs as a young man for drunks
who had no idea who I was you had to
make sure you were funny every single
and earn their life I'm pretty sure this
just will perform a few drunks yeah I'm
pretty sure there are quite a few drunks
and I'm pretty sure they throw stuff to
it their computer yeah how did ya buy a
quick plug if you want to what go back
and watch the Virginia Tech show it is
on seer TV it doesn't see it is my firm
uh club members a future shows will be
streamed to YouTube live on campus just
so you know so anything could happen but
we came out in the audience was just
ready and they were supportive and it
was a huge cheer I've never once in my
life had like a standing O just for
walking out and I could see how people
have seen so many people including some
conservatives out how they've fallen and
you see that with Justin Trudeau and you
see it with President Trump it felt
really good to see that our monologue
jokes all these bits just did really
really well live they're like okay we
get a laugh in the room of ten people
who ever in our in our pitch room but
who's gonna see a whole audience of
people on board and not offended clued
in the cancer joke by the way it's true
they were on board with us um roughly
there were some really rough ones thank
you for supporting us by the way if I
get a terminal illness totally okay to
laugh at me I already know spend
computer well for sure haha you have
stage four boil cancer
Beebe death the comedy gold I don't
think understand comedy spend computer
but I realize that this is something
that could really go to people's head
because you have people who will perform
they get a thunderous applause or a
president or a prime minister how do you
get so far along the trail a good
example is how does he say to spirited
and not realize it because he's
surrounded by people who his baseline
was standing OH and then he said LGBTQA
AI and it just goes from there and then
P and then he does even looked back to
see if the people are clapping anymore
she goes to spirited and assumes that he
has the audience in his pocket and
they're gonna want to go along with him
same thing with President Donald Trump
even a lot of conservatives going we
really want to spend this money in a
military parade if you are surrounded by
yes men we've talked about how that's a
problem but they're also too
Tally's to approaching not only a live
performance but to approaching life and
we talked about this remember after the
show I said everyone was on a high I
said yeah but listen the next audience
hasn't seen that they weren't there
clapping the jokes that we had that
works that it worked tonight but the
next audience they haven't seen it every
single time and I've always tried to do
this with every single show that we do
here when we went hashtag never daily
every time we bring in a new guest every
time we try a new sketch every time we
try to expand or hire a new person I go
okay here's the baseline we have to earn
the audience we have to earn the laughs
we have to earn your trust
every single time starting at zero you
probably owe us really well as a
comedian who when you do shows back to
back the same night yes that's that's a
whole I don't I can't wrap my head
around the energy that goes into doing
it one time nailing it they'd be like
okay back to zero but the difference is
here's the difference if we did two
shows a night we still would have had a
much better show than say if we were
just doing a random show in a mic
because people are there to see us and
it's great and we want you to be there
and we are incredibly grateful but just
like people tried to call us in the
Germany taxing people will tell us that
they don't necessarily like maybe the
Trudeau's people tell us if the camera
was wrong or if the sound was wrong I
want you to call us on it you can live a
life where you assume the baseline as
everyone loves you and you continue on
your merry way and guess what happens
that's they become out of touch that's
that's how ego absolutely destroys you
and we've seen it then you become the
guy talking about how at one time I was
on Carson right you see this all the
time you see old and bitter previously
you know huge Hollywood acts and you see
it you see how it weighs on them in the
truth is humbling yourself before that
is actually a lot less painful in the
world doing it for you so imagine this
you go out to an audience next time and
you've got that in your head they're
gonna they're gonna applaud they're
gonna love me but maybe something went
wrong maybe for some reason they weren't
let in early maybe they were waiting
they're out in the freezing cold and
rain for two hours and now they come in
five minutes before the show and you're
expecting applause and love and instead
they're pissed and they're ready to go
home
how do you think you're gonna do better
if you come out and you go okay these
people we haven't performed them yet
we've got to earn it or if you go out
and you're expecting the applause and
it's not there cuz here's the deal
every single person who's had any
success in their life and every single
person watching this will experience
success to some degree whether it's
personally financially any person here
will experience success at some point
and every single person that same person
if you're listening right now will also
be taken down a peg or two and if you're
expecting to be up here if you're coming
in with an attitude of entitlement that
well people love me I'm great guess what
it's gonna be that much more painful for
you when you're taken down
humble yourself or the world will do it
for you and it stings and that's one
because we do these live shows and we go
forward I've told you guys that's why
we're recalibrating it went really well
Virginia Tech but if when we go to SMU
we have some changes to make some new
sketches the show is always new because
the monologue is new always the jokes
are new the sketches are new but we've
made sure to tell the audience and the
same thing we do the show here on
YouTube on Sierra to be from Mudd Club
members every single time we flip on the
cameras I tell everyone here listen
yesterday doesn't matter today you've
got to earn it you've got to act as
though no one knows who you are no one
cares who you are and this stands alone
and I wish more conservatives did that
because we've talked about this a lot of
time people has come in and they assume
that you want to hear them lecture
they're kind of building the life will
last weeks touchdown right exactly
doesn't add it all your points this week
last touchdown does not help you in
tonight's game two ways to approach life
assume you're gonna win assume you're
getting credit for you did before or
assume that nothing is given to you in
every single time you have to earn that
audience you have to earn that laugh you
have to earn that dollar you have to
earn that trust you have to earn that
respect here's the deal there are two
ways to approach life we're talking one
of them guarantees you that no matter
what happens it's at least a pleasant
surprise
and the other guarantees monumental
soul-crushing defeat the moment you
aren't at your peak and no one stays at
their peak forever so thank you so much
for making Virginia Tech a great show
and we'll have more shows coming up low
announces probably next week cannot wait
we are trying to earn you as an audience
every single time we never take you for
granted
thank you so much it was really touching
to have that many people come out really
appreciate we shout out to crazy people
from just catch one
[Music]